tu fais pas fameux cool brecker
classique parce que t'es pas du tout mon
style pardon mais j'aime les grandes
blondes tech microsoft works ajustements
patente et là je vais quand même prendre
ton numéro pour un pote
ouais bof sur ma chérie vous êtes tout
va bien c'est son père est pas lâcher
son écran depuis trois mois
thomas est mort vers sparring du
fabuleux je suis trop contente
chut je vais vous aider moi je pense
qu'on peut construire certaines agences
devront repasser son permis
je pense qu en dessous d'un certain âge
on devrait un peu fermé ce ailleurs
qu'il est en pleine dépression
cette maison aux autres qu'ils me les
cassaient les baguettes elle mange tout
avec des baguettes ces pratiques pour
manger tu n'en fais deux [ __ ] de bouts
de bois
on n'est pas en chine
[ __ ] canapé de merde ça cool earth
mais petr couleurs c'est un message
message qui dit bien avoir des chiffres
et des lettres via un derrick tu veux
avoir une vie digne de ce nom de marie
toi ma fille ma femme c'est tout des cas
ce qu'on vient nous pourrons chez nous
pas de chez nous je vais parler d'un
truc ce serait peut-être l'occasion
s'acheter un chez nous et c'est
différent mais je me barre sur les
marrons
voyons ce fait une sortie ce soir
égaré
de retour à l'adolescence
laser ce que j'aurais dû faire plus
longtemps le musée un pédophile étape la
machine r j'ai commencé à me trouver des
petits plans cul ok mais moi j'en ai ma
place joffre peu plus d'avoir affaire à
des a déclaré
belga ce n'est pas lui mais [ __ ]
gilbert ils sont mi temps